так випадкового пляшку в центрі вигляді не
заїжджайте баликін вестер це
єврочиновники
виріж у цю частку знайдеш її українську
навіть компанії нак нафтогаз україни лого
компанії проходить
про стан мінусу швидко презентувати їм і
модель поділ газового монополіста
але крім компанії напряму вийду пляшка
транспортування азоту його продажів ти
ключового міг нафтогаз нафтогаз c
компанія каддафі переможну функцію
транспорт у вані та азовській мартін
ідеальністю дорогою так буде ми не
можемо говорити і про право або
реалізацію ринку газу в Україні
mabuta доступ цієї компанії досі у
ринку цілісного будокай лібералізації
або будучи market знаєш youtube
оновлення нафтогазу будуть поетапними
метати їй з уст ричі за брата юні
транзит озу вирок 4
нафтогазу на стеку секрет ніші
журналісти попросили чути і не вище
залу засідання а й на диво 9 буває з
вуст мова пиши плити роки на без перерви
це образу за два remo мало не гуч
непрямого цілях пояснили ДВС
рятуйте між собою члени української
докладати і
одні нафтогаз та мінекономіки хоче
вивести спить глада монополіста а за
транспорт на систему і обдурюють і транзит
блокадного порожнього про крем не за лижник
компанії вирішать ці віки поважаю тюн-авто
газі і можна буде залучити до європейської
компанії до транзиту
і тим самим оранта ватою на день є
україни на нашу думку церкви 1000 жив
його найготовіша ще ви канат і ховаємо
цю про якумо так часто хурму просто
панночка транзитних потоків газу
території України та кіно рази проносять
щодо жарище на менше 2 мільярдів
доларів особисто а потенції ну ми помиємо
уникне цю цифру ішиба чині травня
міністерства на такі бугельні
промислової sti
вона хоче забрати і всі дочки та піт
спадкоємно в тобі столітті займаєте
транс цьому газу пити свої крило
приходили якісь моделі здається відкриття
українських труб для інвесторів створено
your мова ще пивна їх часто заволодів
Росія інвестуєш виправдати їй і
Дункан визначають
у росіян за
ти була так а можна і весь харчування до б
може особі поставити і шуму ванни це ж
на зарубали раниш її серце було в них
їх інтересах ми віримо ще буде як він
currency c добра конкуренція у цьому
джонас презентовано їх моделей європейців
не задоволені лам українській стороні
дали два ти ж не
щоб до протити механізм реформа
нафтогазу